my name is Manuel Serrano as you can
probably guess from an accent I'm coming
from France where I'm a researcher at
inria which is a French Research
Institute in computer science
so since a couple of here have been
working on JavaScript and in particular
in trying to implement and design a
static compiler for this language and
this is what I will present today so I
will start slowly not assuming that you
know all the details and all the
subtleties that come with this language
so we'll try to make a smooth
introduction and then I will present
some of the results we have obtained
so JavaScript and you see the title a
nightmare for compilers and I will try
to show you why most of the things I
will present in this introduction are
well known but still I may assume that
some of you are not so familiar with all
these subtleties
so let me start with this example and
for a while let's assume that we are a c
or a Java programmer even if you are not
exactly familiar with all technique of
compilers that are deploying and all the
optimization you may have a rather
precise ID of the code you will get if
you will try to compile this with let's
say gcc-o2
probably you know that you will get
something like that because you know
that a and I will be registers you know
that the loop will just be incrementing
a register comparing something Reading
from a contiguous memory area and just
jumping for the loop
so far so good
so now let's assume that we are no
longer a c programmer but let's assume
that we are JavaScript programmer the
story looks like the same because the
syntax is the same but what is going on
actually
well it all depends because if a is an
array as before the semantics of the
program is exactly the same as the
semantics of a Java program
but the problem with JavaScript is that
a might be something else and in
particular M might be an array but you
can remove properties from an array and
you can store property in the Prototype
chain of that array and then when you
are executing the loop when you reach a
of one you no longer find the value in
the array itself but you have to follow
the Prototype shape so you see in the C
code you were just reading from a
contiguous memory area in this code it's
no longer that same story because you
have to follow the Prototype chain so
the code that you will generate will
obviously be much more complicated
but things can be even worse
because a might be something else and an
array a might be an object and this is
perfectly fine as long as this object
has property named after the integer we
are using for the array and this is
correct because the JavaScript semantics
tells you that when you are accessing
something from an object you first
convert the property into a string and
you make a lookup in something like a
hash table so this program is perfectly
fine and you see I have pay attention
not to have contiguous objects or
properties here because I go from one
zero and two so really forget about this
idea of rigiding from a contiguous
memory area it will be a totally
different matter
but they can do even worse because if I
change slightly my program and if I
replace I plus plus with I plus equal
one you know in JavaScript a plus plus
and I plus equal one are not the same if
I do that I might even be something else
and an integer it might be a string and
then in that context I will concatenate
things in my string and making an index
from that that value
so you see the ID we add with C where it
was pretty obvious that the
implementation of a loop was just a
bunch of assembly instruction clearly
with JavaScript forget about that it
will be a totally different story
totally different
problem for the compiler and the
difficulty here we have is that the
syntax of the language tell us very
little things and so it does not provide
significant help to the compiler
let me keep digging a little bit more
deeply into the specificities of
JavaScript if we have this piece of code
it's pretty obvious how GCC will compile
that basically it will generate that
accessing a value from one pointer is
just one SMB instruction pretty obvious
pretty straightforward you don't even
need to have a smart compiler for
generating that what about JavaScript
well same syntax as Java but the story
is now radically different and here you
see excerpt of the specification of the
language so if you want to execute o dot
P you have to follow these semantic
steps and the first thing you notice is
that in this semantic function you have
several steps to execute several tests
several conditions to verify several
several branch that you have to take
depending on the value you get the thing
that is even more complex is that you
see at the very first line here
the first thing that the semantics tells
us is that if you want to get the
property well you have to invoke another
cementing function even before doing
this dispatch with stitches over there
what is this other semantic function
that you have to execute well this is
the one that will tell you how you have
to follow the Prototype channel so this
is actually implementing a loop you
check do I do I have my property in that
object yes or no if it is there I will
return it to the other function that
will mess the testing otherwise I will
follow the Prototype chain
but you see here this function it is
using another function here so what is
this as a function well this is the one
so this one tells you that yes make the
lookup in the hash table and if you find
the value you see there is this weird
syntax somewhere around here which is
allocate allocate an object and return
that object that is when you are
accessing a property from a from an
object the semantics tells you that
first you have some to make some HIPAA
location
and you of course the compiler will be
able to
somehow not execute all these steps but
once again remember in C accessing a
property was just one assembly
instruction here you imagine all the
paths that we have to follow in order to
make the efficient property access
so mitigation for that problem has been
discovered while in the past
and they are used in all JavaScript
implementation they get rid of most most
of these steps but still we are pretty
far away from the performance of C when
accessing an object
maybe as a last example I would like to
to
show you today function call
here we have a c code where we have an
external function f and we invoke it
with two arguments
one and two we get the result and we sum
it with three
okay in C pretty simple you just pack
your argument in the stack if you are
using an xa86 platform here you just
push the argument on the stack you make
the call you get back the result you you
add three you return you're done
pretty simple pretty straightforward
what happened with JavaScript well
JavaScript is dynamically typed so the
first thing that you have to verify is
is f really a function am I allowed to
call F if I'm not I have to throw an
exception so exceptions are involved
here
let's assume that f is a function next
thing you have to verify yes is f
function executing two arguments because
it might be that F just accept one or
zero argument and inside case you will
have to drop the extra argument that you
are passing to the call
on the contrary it might be that f is
expecting more than two arguments and
then you will have to complement the
missing arguments
when I say you will have two it means
that the runtime system will have two so
it means that you will have to do
something at runtime
if F happens to be using this special
value arguments with an S it means that
you will have to hip allocate a value
representing all the arguments that you
are passing to this function and you
will have to deliver that value which
has a dynamic extent to to the function
which will be able to use it as it wish
then you will have to assign the Zeus
value and then eventually you will make
the call so you see once again we have
the Simplicity of C which is just
pushing something into the stack or in
register depending on your platform
while with JavaScript totally different
story
and once again the problem is that the
structure of the program does not really
help the compiler the syntax tells us
not sufficiently does not provide
sufficient information so so that we are
able to implement that efficiently
okay so rate of time compilation of this
crazy language
because I'm not assuming that all of you
are exactly and precisely familiar with
all the technique we are using when we
are implementing a compiler a very brief
introduction of how we are usually
implementing programming languages
on the very left part you have
interpreter and typically this is what
you find for python the C python
implementation is just an interpreter
interpreter are used for fast
development cycle because you execute as
you go with your program you read your
program you execute so it's very
convenient convenient for making some
experiment
fast development cycle as I said but the
downside is that you have very slow
execution
at the very right part of my drawing you
have heard of time compiler static
compiler which a couple of years ago was
were just called compilers today we have
to say aot compiler
typically this is what you get for
languages such as ocml GCC rest all
these kind of languages
slow development cycle because usually
compiling statically one of this program
takes a while if you have a large C code
and you try gcc-o3 you will notice that
it takes a while
complex implementation because
developing such compiler is a complex
task and but the good side is that it
delivers good performances for static
languages
in the middle you have things that are
just a little bit of interpreter a
little bit of static compiler you have
typically bytecode compiler such as a
Java C compiler here the purpose of the
bytecode compiler is to simplify a
little bit the execution by implementing
some operations such as for instance a
resolving variable names maybe preparing
the construction of the execution stack
but nothing too fancy and nothing too
complicated
and then you have jit compilers and jit
compilers are typically paper or what
you get in all the commercial JavaScript
implementation
JavaScript Implement sorry jit compilers
allows fast development cycle because as
a user you do not even notice that the
compiler is existing you just run and
you just start your program in each run
and it's it's under all of everything
for you it's super complex
implementation because you have to
implement an interpreter a compiler and
something that is able to replace the
code that you are interpreting with the
call that you will get generated by the
compiler so it's really extra complexity
and it's quite convenient for dynamic
languages in particular because the jit
compiler is able to do some profiling so
discovering during the execution what is
going on and what is the best code it
can generate
what we are trying is we are trying to
build this Hub compiler which is a
static compiler for JavaScript that is
not taking the same approach as jit
compiler so this compiler exists it's
called objs it's an opportunistic
compiler and you will see what I mean by
that later on
support full-fledged JavaScript
it is almost compliant with the latest
version of JavaScript it is also almost
compliant with node.js which means that
you could potentially use this compiler
as a replacement for node.js but
it optimize the core language but there
are some part of the language that it
does not optimize yet so it means that
for this part you will not get good
performances and typically some Library
functions are not well optimized or some
data structures are not well optimized
neither such as floating Point numbers
that the compiler does not optimize so
far
so the first question is does really
does it really make sense to try to
compile statically a language such as
JavaScript
well the motivation for this work are
numerous
the first one is that on some platforms
you are not allowed to write the
executable memory
so for for this platform you cannot rely
on a jit compiler typically if you want
to build your own JavaScript
implementation for iOS for instance you
are not allowed to change the executable
memory so you cannot do it forget about
it so you have either to use an
interpreter or a static compiler
then you have platform which have a very
limited memory platforms such as
microcontroller for which you cannot
consider embedding a jitcompiler in the
platform because memory is not enough
then you have executions that are very
short typically cloud services are even
imagined for instance a shell command
imagine that you want to implement LS in
JavaScript
maybe just running LS is too fast too
quick so the jit compiler will not even
have the time to optimize LS before the
execution has completed so for this kind
of an execution a Statin compiler might
help
and also as a researcher this is an
intriguing question because all the
current implementation also currently
fast implementation are used jit
compiler but does it mean that it is not
possible to build a static compiler for
such a language or how far can we go in
this attempt of building and optimizing
ad-of-time compiler for JavaScript
so these are all of these are a little
bit of my motivations
so the question then the second question
is how to attack the problem which seems
difficult
well we will first of all we will
accommodate the technique of jit
compiler to static compilation and I
will show you more precisely what it
means
then we will reuse all the thing we know
about compilers and all the things we
know about optimization that is we will
do a little bit of typing we will do a
little bit of data flow analysis A
Little Bit Of Control flow analysis and
what we will do is a lot of optimistic
heuristic and this is the point that I
will develop in the rest of this
presentation
so optimistic compilation the ID is
pretty simple pretty straightforward
consider a function such as this one the
Fibonacci function
well CID is just we will generate
several versions for such a function one
version specialize and optimize for a
ddke type and a generic version and we
will just make a dispatch selecting
according to the type which version to
select and if we are happy enough that
the argument are of the optimized time
we Branch to the efficient version and
we are done
so why is that significantly better
because in the optimized version we will
be able to use dedicated operators that
are not strictly following the
JavaScript semantics but that are much
more efficient and also because using
the type inference we will be able for
instance here and there on the recursive
call not to go through the dispatch but
directly branching to the optimized
version
so CID is pretty simple and more or less
it's doing statically what a jit
compiler will do selecting the Prototype
and generating several version
so the question is how do we select the
type for which we want to generate this
version and here the ID is absolutely
straightforward in the past when we were
doing type inference we were always
trying to find the most generic type
representing all possible execution in
this context we are not interested at
all by these types the only types we are
interested in are the type for which a
compiler is able to generate a good code
so instead of trying to infer the most
General type we'll just try to find out
which is the type for which a compiler
is able to generate its best code and
this is the type we will select this is
the type we will pick and for the rest
we don't care
so how does it work it's extremely
straightforward
we walk through the program and for each
expression we apply a rule and the rule
tells us for this variable used in this
expression if it was of that type I will
be able to generate a good code or a bad
code and we just for each expression we
apply all possible rules that we have
and at the end of the day we just check
what what has been produced by the rule
and we select the most efficient type
so what are these rules looking like
there's of this kind we say when you
have a
property access from an object x a
property e if x was an object then we
will be able to generate a better code
because we could be we would be able to
avoid a type check
if in addition we knew that e was an
integer if x was an array we would even
be able to generate a better code
because we have dedicated operation for
accessing arrays with integers
if the property happens to be length
then if the value was an array or a
string we would be able to generate an
even better code because we have
dedicated cases for these two special
cases
if we see an assignment as strings are
read-only we know that we can forget
about string so this is why we use this
minus minus infinity type here right
here saying that we are not interested
in having X being an array a string
sorry but we are interested in having X
being an array and we keep going with
all these rules we have plenty of them I
just mentioned presented a bunch of them
but we have much more we see we have
rules of this kind where we say if this
is a bit wise operation if the object
happens to be an integer then we will be
able to generate good code otherwise
we'll have to go through a dispatch so
we are not interested in other cases
so let me show you on an example how
this works let's consider this function
that is just reversing an array of
values
and we just apply the rule blindly one
one after the other
we have an uh an expression of this kind
in the program a of length so by
applying rule one we say Okay egg please
the compiler make it an object
but by applying role two we also have
dedicated rules for array and for
Strings
we have an axis of this kind so by rule
one we increment the object type for
this variable a
the type inference tells us that I is an
integer so we increase the weight of
array and string for the possible type
for a and we keep going like that
and at the end we observe that okay the
best possible type is a being an array
and you see that absolutely simple
because it's just one pass you just
accumulate the weights and at the end
you just pick the most most probable or
the most optimized optimizable one
and then when you are done with this
type you just generate the code as I
presented before you have your dispatch
your dedicating function the generic one
and on the two possible calls is a you
are able to Branch directly to the
optimized version or you go through the
generic version and that's it and this
is how we implement this sort of option
opportunistic compilation
we have just generated the best possible
code and we have made a bet in some
sense we have guessed that this was a
code that has that is likely to be used
this is one of the thing we have in the
compiler but this is not it
JavaScript is a very big language
core language is complex because you
have all these prototype things you have
a inheritance which is complicated the
language the language keep growing you
have extended set of libraries
so for a very small academic team it's
not really possible to implement
efficiently all this aspect of
JavaScript
so what we did instead of considering
JavaScript and generating native code we
consider JavaScript and we generate
scheme code so this may seem a little
bit weird but actually scheme is the
original motivation for JavaScript
so scheme is actually very close to
JavaScript except that scheme is much
more simpler and it has a cleaner
semantics many of the dynamic aspects
which are very complicated to deal with
with JavaScript are absent from schema
so scheme can be considered as an
interesting Intermediate Language for
JavaScript
so we have been doing that and we reuse
a scheme compiler that generates C code
so actually it's a Full Compilation
chain is we go from scheme from
JavaScript to scheme scheme to C and C2
assembly code or object code
okay now let me show you just another
example of this idea of optimal
opportunistic compilation when scheme is
involved so if you are not familiar with
skim don't be too afraid with this piece
of code I will show you the very same
one in JavaScript in just the next slide
but
still
here we are defining a function called
get setor which will return a function
setor which is defined here this create
an object and the only interesting part
here is that function uses two three
variables CNT and base and this one is a
floating point this one is an integer
this is the only part which is
interesting and here you see we are
assigning a new value to CNT which means
that we are mutating this free variable
okay oops sorry my arrow is a little bit
weird how is that implemented or what is
happening at runtime when we are
executing this piece of code well here
you see this is the assembly code for
this function over there
this is the value of the floating point
this is the value for the CNT variable
and this is the object representing this
function this set of function in memory
this is very classical this is a
standard way of compiling scheme a
function which is a data structure
contains its free variable so this is a
heap allocated structure
okay enough for schema so now the very
same thing in JavaScript exactly the
same program exactly the same meaning I
have my set of function I return the
setoff function I have two variables
three in this value in this function and
I assign CNT so exactly the same exactly
the same program
what is the difference with JavaScript
well in JavaScript you need this extra
memory and this extra objects because in
JavaScript a function is a regular
object so you can assign Properties or
you can store values arbitrarily as you
want in your in your function
so you see in scheme we add just this
object any JavaScript we have the hobo
head which is all this new object that
has appeared
so clearly you can see that JavaScript
will not be as efficient as schema by
any by no means
but what do we do with that well the
idea is that okay
in the general case a JavaScript
function or JavaScript closure will be
an easy weight object but in many cases
we know what we will be doing with the
function and in particular for this kind
of cases which are extremely frequent
you are just invoking the forage
function on an array and you are passing
here a narrow function so the idea is
that it's it would be a shame to
allocate a full-fledged JavaScript
function for this Arrow function because
we are just invoking the JavaScript
library function for each which is not
doing anything special with that
function except calling it
so so where we compile that is
we compile we generate this scheme code
that is we are assuming that forage is
actually the forage of the RL library of
JavaScript
and then instead of building a true
JavaScript function we just allocate On
The Stack
a scheme function a lightweight scheme
function and this function here
and we call so this function JS array
maybe for each and how is this function
implemented it just check is the
receiver a regular array that is not
overriding for each
and if it is which is always
it's just directly invokes that function
without allocating anything and if it is
not then it goes to the slow path
so we are somehow making a bet here we
are guessing that yes the user is not
overriding for each of arrays and yes he
is using for each with arrays and if he
is then we have a very efficient code AS
efficient as the scheme code and if it
is not then yes we will follow the slow
path so this is another example of how
we are using this idea of opportunistic
or optimistic compilation in the static
context
good so what about performances
when you oh sorry when you are dealing
with JavaScript and JavaScript
efficiency
it is impossible to get any paper
accepted if you are not presenting
official JavaScript benchmarks so you
have to go through this jet stream
octane you name it although this
Benchmark are known to be flowed to have
biases that you don't want to deal with
but still you have to present these
values
so here we are for Hub compared to V8
and spider monkey and as you see other
player
so hop is in yellow and you see that in
this test Street it seems to perform not
so well
but actually is our reason for that
first as I mentioned before Hub is not
optimizing floating Point numbers so all
the benchmarks that are using logic
Point numbers have poor performances
with hub
and then you have other benchmarks for
which are special patterns and if you
miss these pattern then your performance
are awful and a hub is not able to
optimize all of them some because we
don't know how to optimize them and some
because we simply don't care and I will
show you two examples of these patterns
let's consider Delta blue here
into code you see this pattern this
direction is just actually this
implementation of an enumer but it is
used as an object everywhere so if the
compiler is not able to detect that this
is a constant this is an allocated
object that is never used as an object
only
assigned here and make a replacement
that is a constant propagation here the
type inference is not able to do a good
job and your performance will be doomed
a fully for this very case app is able
to optimize that but there are other
cases slightly similar to this where Hub
is not able to do a good job
let me show you an another example my
favorite one it's an example uh so
crypto Shea one as you know as you can
imagine it's a function implementing a
crypto function used in a crypto Library
and in this code you see this function
and you see it's an interesting one
because what it does is it create an
array
and here in a loop it executes this
or bit or operation but you can notice
that array bin has not been initialized
before
so actually this code is totally broken
because if someone assigns something in
the array.prototype object your crypto
Library will be totally correct
so Cisco makes no sense at all so yes up
is not able to optimize that and it has
poor performance on that benchmark
but really is that a problem we are not
optimizing this wrong code
and and you have this kind of problem in
many of these octane jet stream and so
on so what we did is we designed another
test Suite which for which we got our
programmer from different sources we we
took program coming directly from npm
npm packages that have no dependencies
we use this test uh seat program in our
test Suite we parted some program from
other languages and typically from
Python and from scheme and so we design
a large set of new benchmarks I
presented just some of them here and you
see because we are interested in
comparing jit performance and head of
time compiler performance it's not a
Peak Performance that we are interested
in but we are also interested in
understanding how the performance evolve
if the complexity of the problem evolves
so here in the horizontal axis you see
the program is getting more so the data
set the input of the program is becoming
more complex and so the execution last
longer and you see how the comparison in
between the different implementation
evolved over the time depending on the
complexity of the problem
so you see for this program hope
performs similarly to other jit compiler
so here basic it's a basic interpreter
uh marked it's a markdown compiler sorry
I have to grab my glasses
level it's a scheme interpreter
and a bag is just as implementation of a
small gamma using recursive function and
integer manipulation
just to keep going with some other
example a moment is it is the most
popular package on npm and it's a
package dealing with dates and the
runtime implementation of data in Hub is
not so great we are not very good at
implementing date function so it is not
performing so well but it's just twice
slower than uh Spider monkey for
instance so it's not that good but it's
not that powerful either
here it's a program passing the command
line and this one checking Computing a
unique identifiers this program is
interesting it's a version of the
recharge program from octane but where
we have introduced proxy object each
time we create a value and you see that
up outperform all the other
implementation and we know why because
we have a special optimization for proxy
but the interesting point here is that
even for a very Dynamic feature in a
static context we are able to deliver
good performance
so that's it for executioner
the promise of having a more efficient
memory consumption here you can observe
it that yes indeed Hub is really uh
provide better performance when we are
talking about memory because you don't
have to embed the jit compiler in your
hip when you are running your program
and we observe that for the virtual size
and the resident size
and I think I'm done so just in in
conclusion we have built this static
compiler it's fully support JavaScript
it uses a lot of optimistic and optimal
opportunistic techniques and these are
described in the paper we are publishing
it it is not as good as the most
efficient jit compiler yet but it
deliver competitive performance that is
more most of the time we are in a Range
where we are as fast or two or 2.5 times
slower than jit compiler but nothing
worse
but in terms of memory footprint we are
much more efficient because we are not
embedding the compiler
and I thank you for your attention and I
don't know if we have time for a
question
no we don't
no what I think what you are referring
to is a profile guided optimizations
um jit compiler I don't know because it
requires an infrastructure that and the
Rob contact system is not ready for that
profile guided optimization yes
definitely yes and hub is doing a little
bit of that but I did not mention that
in this presentation because so far the
result I have obtained are slightly
disappointing
because uh with profile guided
optimization more or less we are able to
reduce generated code size but we are
not accelerating executions
and my guess for that it's because with
profile guided optimization maybe you
can remove some of the guards that you
have or your dispatch but this generally
are optimized by the processor and by
the branch predictor of the processor so
there is something that I don't really
understand here but
yeah this is this should be interesting
but uh
not so far
so no we don't have all the old program
because it compiles modules
so inside the module yes we are able to
do some Global analysis and yes I think
we are able to do a better type analysis
in particular because you are we are
using abstract interpretation for
executing everything
but in the end you know a jit that is
able to do some precise profiling will
also probably be able to discover the
types that we are discovering
so it's not so clear that it is a huge
advantage
maybe but maybe not
The Next Step I think for me is rather
to try to reuse the types that are
generated by the typescript compiler
because this is a different settings and
probably more friendly to static
computation so this is the next thing I
will experiment with
I don't really know you know with these
languages
JavaScript or maybe python there is this
performance Cliff phenomenon I don't
know if you are familiar with that the
idea that as as long as you are in a
subset where the compiler is able to
understand what you are doing you have
good performance but if you change it a
slightly bit somewhere all of a sudden
maybe your performance will degrade with
1000 x ratio for a reason that you as a
programmer cannot understand
for hope I'm experimenting something
slightly different you know in
JavaScript you have this different mode
you have use strict and uh
in the past Google has tried uh what was
the name used strong or something like
that which was even stricter than you
strict and for hop I'm using something
similar I have a dedicated mode where
some of the JavaScript
features are removed are not allowed and
then if you use this mode syntactically
JavaScript the data structure are
compatible with JavaScript but there are
some operations that you are not allowed
to execute and then you are guaranteed
to have better performance but you are
sacrificing a little bit of the
dynamicity of the language
but this is compatible with the rest so
some of your module might be in that
mode and the other modules in regular
JavaScript node and you combine that and
that's okay
so this is the approach I'm following
yeah I don't know uh
in theory I could say yes I will spend
time and I will succeed in optimizing
that
I don't know maybe there are
difficulties that I'm not even
suspecting
honestly I cannot answer that question
I I'm not even sure that this is doable
to be totally honest I think so but I'm
I cannot guarantee that
okay thank you very much thank you for
your attention
[Applause]